tomorrow will bring a lot of feelings
for women of all races since
harris will be the first black south
asian and female vice president
our country has ever seen eight news now
reporter madison kimbrough spoke to
members of the naacp
to get their perspective on tomorrow's
ceremony
yes yes history will be made tomorrow
and i talked to our local naacp
chapter about the impact this new
presidency will have
on our country particularly when it
comes to the matter of racial equality
and there is hope january 20th 2021
history will be made president-elect joe
biden will take on the biggest role
there is
becoming the president of the united
states of america
but he won't do it alone as a woman will
become our nation's vice president
vice president-elect kamala harris will
take center stage tomorrow
representing millions of americans whose
voices remain
unheard for the black communities it
gives everybody hope
there's something to be said when
children can relate to someone that
looks like them
in all facets of life so it's absolutely
amazing and we're just excited to see
what they're going to be able to do
with this new presidency upon us comes a
whole new path forward
something the naacp supports we are so
excited
to know that joe biden and kamala harris
are going to begin this administration
with principal leadership with values
that are aligned with the naacp las
vegas
values such as respect inclusiveness and
understanding
listening to the voices of people of
color and black individuals
something shanti and hallman agree has
been lacking in our country
there's a different tone now we have a
whole different set of things a lot of
feelings and sentiments about black and
african american people and people of
color
overall the naacp in las vegas hopes for
open discussion and inclusiveness with
this new administration upon us
and to see such a diverse cabinet at the
forefront
is a great start and the inauguration
ceremonies are slated to begin at 9 a.m
pacific time
tomorrow as president-elect joe biden
will be sworn in
as our 46th president of the united
states reporting live in the newsroom
madison kimbrough
8 news now